5 mai il faut pas hésiter alors mettez
des gants si vous voulez des pinces ou
ce que vous voulez mais votez fait
abaisser le plus bas possible ben
[Musique]
chacun chacune d'entre vous
cette en conscience quel est son devoir
qu'est ce qui a changé en quinze ans
dans le contexte la première fois je
suis un dirigeant socialiste
je parle j'étais ministre en plus je
crois en ses le oui c'est vrai
donc j'étais vraiment très liées à toute
la mouvance socialiste que je avec
laquelle j'avais des divergences mais
surtout une adhésion à ses profondes et
puis nous étions absolument sidéré par
ce qui venait de se passer on n'arrivait
pas à y croire on avait conscience du
danger mais qui était de qui déplaçait
la raison moi j'ai fait une tribune pour
dire qu'il fallait aller voter chirac
les j'ai fait beaucoup de choses de
cette nature le quand on arrive à la
dernière fois la situation est
complètement différente la gauche ait
explosé je suis à la tête d'un ensemble
politique qui en gros se situe dans la
philosophie de gauche mais n'a pas assez
d'histoire il il existe depuis à peine
deux ans n'a pas assez d'histoire pour
que ils se sentent liés à une option que
proclame le responsable en l'occurrence
moi donc je me suis dit comment je me
sors de ça pour pas faire de bêtises
c'est à dire que si je m'étais j'étais
arrivé en disant ah ben écoutez
maintenant c'est clair on fait comme la
dernière fois on vote pour pour macron
contre le pen je provoquer une
déflagration parce que plein de gens
n'étaient pas prêts à entendre un
discours pareil donc j'ai dit vous savez
ce que vous avez à faire est la ruse
c'est qu'on a ouvert comme on le ferait
sans doute grand dans d'autres occasions
comparables un vote parmi les gens qui
parrainait ma candidature et on n'a mis
que deux options un vote et maquereau ou
s'abstenir et on a dit ben voilà la
réponse elle est là c'est vous tous qui
décidez quelle est la consigne que l'on
nomme je crois que c'est une méthode qui
a assez bien fonctionné après je dois la
loyauté de ne pas vous dire ce que moi
même j'ai fait mais
la loyauté à l'égard de ceux qui ont
voté pour moi et qu'ils attendaient que
j'ai cette façon de parler mes
adversaires en ont profité pour dire que
je mettais jeu égal signe égal entre
maquereau et le pen c'est bon c'est de
la basse polémique d'ailleurs vous
auriez pu montrer l'extrait où je dis il
doit pas y avoir une seule voie pour le
pen écoutez quand il ya deux candidats
avec vous il faut pas qu une seule voie
pour en d2 vont tout le monde comprend
mais je ne pouvais pas compte tenu de ce
qui était le mot rapport à ceux qui
m'avaient mandaté 7 millions de voix
c'était la première fois qu'une chose
pareille arrive et qu'un candidat comme
ils disent de la gauche radicale
incarne à ce poids un mouvement
populaire aussi profond donc je pense
que j'ai réagi correctement parce que si
j'avais agi autrement j'aurais plutôt
brutalisés ou indignés ce qui n'était
pas le but de l'opération le but de
l'opération c'était que madame le pen ne
perde
[Musique]